Selena Gomez is back with new music and
it's a Bop we already have this dance
anthem on repeat Selena dropped her
first single since her reported
emotional breakdown back in December
it's called can't get enough and it's a
collab with Benny Blanco J Balvin and
Latin Grammy winning producer tiny the
man behind cardis hit I like it take a
listen guys it's nice to see cell
returning to her roots but the lyrics
are pretty racy Selena shares a writing
credit on the track with Blanco and
valve in fans pointed out how the lyrics
seemed to speak to what Selena is like
when she's in love fully consumed in the
relationship I just feel like people
really want me to be something I'm not
and I only know how to be myself earlier
this Monday by been spilled a little bit
about the new track and working with
Selena I can get enough that's the name
of the song okay
and yeah produced by tiny you know which
is a great producer Benny Blanco and yes
I mean Selena yeah does she sing Spanish
on this one or she going English others
sure one English you know I represent
the Spanish anyway so yeah yeah what was
it like working with her real quick
amazing such a homo girl no great person
I really really I'm really happy that
she's that we can't get enough is Tiny's
first-ever artist release ET caught up
with the fame producer at premio lo
nuestro where he had nothing but praise
for selena and his dream team that must
feel good when you get people like Jay
Bob and Selena Gomez to go yeah I want
to be on this track it's crazy like fun
to hear and not even like think about it
like let's go let's do it because you
know sometimes like a process probably
they're not
or whatever but this was like yo as soon
as they heard it I'm down so it was
amazing I was like working with Selena
Gomez she's she's a queen she's
incredible it's such an honor like to
have her like on my first single it's
just insane so now hopefully we can
continue like to do some more work
together well we hope so too with the
new song here's to hoping Selena
reclaims her crown as the most followed
woman on Instagram
after ariana grande recently de throned
her now this comes after Selena
announced she was taking a break from
social media back in September sharing
with her fans quote I am equally
grateful to be able to step back and
live my life present to the moment I
have been given kindness and
encouragement only for a bit I'm
constantly somebody that likes to grow
and feel like alright what could I be
better what could I do better at where
where could my confidence be stronger
and one month after her hiatus the 26
year old was hospitalized a source told
ET Selena was having issues with her
physical health
she suffers from lupus and underwent a
kidney transplant and her frustration
with it led her to seek mental health
treatment it wasn't long before Selena
completed her stay in the facility after
being released a source told us she was
quote in good spirits feeling a lot
stronger and happy to be spending time
with family and friends SEL returned to
Instagram to wish everyone a Happy New
Year revealing 2018 was a year of
self-reflection challenges and growth
now guys we love to see Selena happy
healthy and blessing us with new music
are you loving this new club banger now
as always we will keep you updated with
all the latest on the singer so be sure
to subscribe to ET until next time I'm
at Kourtney underscore tezo know bye for
now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]